hello free code cam friends my name is
tobias and today i will guide you
through a very
important topic how to undo mistakes
with git because i think this is really
one of the core skills to master as a
software developer how to
undo mistakes how to deal with them and
how to undo them because
the beginner and the professional alike
we all
make mistakes but the professional knows
how to deal with them and how to undo
them so
let's see how we can do that and how we
can learn to better deal with mistakes
but first a huge shout out to the people
at free code camp
for doing an awesome job of teaching
people how to code for free and
thanks for letting me help you with that
mission
a couple of words about me and about why
i chose
this very specific topic so
one of the reasons is i am part of the
team behind tower
tower is a git desktop gui for mac and
for windows
and we've been around since 2011 and
helped over
100 000 software developers all over the
world in companies big and small
let's say work more easily with the git
version control system work more
productively with git
and today's workshop will mostly be on
the command line get on the command line
so you don't have to
have tower installed don't worry
and the reason why i chose this topic
undoing
mistakes is that sometimes i feel like
that little man here in the middle of
the lion cage
there's so many things to do wrong
there's so many things that can break in
a complex software project today
and things will break let's let's be
honest they will break
and this is what git is actually for git
is our safety net
git is therefore helping us undo
things and recover from mistakes
and the the thing that i noticed in
talking to to other developers is
that many of them don't know that git
has these
amazing capabilities to help you
undo mistakes so i think that it's
really really crucial to learn
what git can do and how you can do that
and that's
what we will talk about today in this
workshop
i have 17 cases of how to mess up and
to correct with me today and they'll get
a little bit more complex towards the
end so depending on your own
level of gift knowledge you might want
to concentrate on the first half
little easier cases and and then the
second half is more
complicated so depending on your own
level of of skills
all right i would say let's dive in and
start with the first
very simple case so let's talk about how
to discard
local changes in a file so you made some
changes in in a local file and haven't
committed
those changes yet and you notice well
not the best work
i want to undo those changes and get
back the last
committed version of that file let's see
how we can do that
so we have a couple of changes here
so let's take a closer look at what we
did
with imprint html with git
diff and the file name i can take a
closer look at the changes that happened
there and let's do that for imprint html
okay so i changed the the title tag here
and let's say
this isn't what i really wanted and i
want to undo that and get back to what i
last committed and the command to use
here is
git restore and then the name of the
file in print html
in in the past you might have used git
checkout to do that
that's also possible of course but the
git restore command a little bit
newer you could say is a little bit
clearer
that the purpose is very limited of git
restore
so there's less ambiguity around that
so git restore and the name of the file
and let's see what that what that did
get status voila imprint html is not
amongst the changed files
anymore so we undid that
all right git restore and
the file name along the the course of
this little workshop you will see those
yellow warning boxes on my slides and
first case first warning box i'm very
sorry but that's life
in these first couple of cases we're
talking about uncommitted local changes
changes you have not committed to the
git repository yet
and the thing to keep in mind here is if
you undo
those if you discard those they're gone
right you can't get those back so be a
little bit careful with those
and don't rush things
all right number two similar but a
little bit different
here we didn't only make changes we also
deleted
a whole file and let's say we
desperately want that file back and see
how we can do that
all right this is case number two sorry
and again get status to see what we have
okay so let's see that let's say that
arrow html
the deletion of that file wasn't our
best move so to get that back
the good news is it's the exact same
command as before git restore and the
name of the file
and if i do that get status so it's not
listed as a changed file anymore
wonderful and let's really make sure
voila here it is back again as a
physical file
in my working copy on my disk so we
brought that back
from the dead
all right again git restore and the file
name of the file you have
deleted and went back number three let's
get a little bit more granular and maybe
more
interesting sometimes not all of the
changes that we made in a file are bad
right
sometimes we have good days or mixed
days and not everything
is bad and we don't want to throw away
we don't want to
discard everything just parts of our
changes and we want to keep
other parts of the changes and this is
possible with git
so let's look at let's look at how to do
that in practice
number three and
let's take a look at what we did with
index.html
and you'll see we have two chunks of
changes here so in the first chunk
i manipulated a list i added some list
items
to to an unordered list and in the
second
chunk here i manipulated a link
so let's say the first one is genius
work
and the second one is bad we want to
keep the first one
and get rid of the second part of the
changes right
so bonus points if you can guess the
command
yes it's git restore again but this time
the secret sauce is dash p
to go down to the patch level and talk
about
individual patches or chunks hunks of
changes
and i think we wanted to do that with
index html
and let's do that so git
now steps through every chunk or hunk of
changes
together with us and asks us a simple
question
down at the bottom do you want to
discard this hunk from the work tree
don't ask me what all of the letters and
options mean i do not know i want to
sleep at night
but it's a simple question do we want to
discard it yes or no that's the most
simple
possibilities and i think we said we
want to keep the first one so
i don't want to discard this no
but the second one i want to get rid of
so yes
discard this all right let's see what we
have
so this is tower this is the graphical
user interface for git that we
make and we work on index html wonderful
so that the second part of the changes
the second chunk
is gone we discarded that but we kept
the first
chunk alive
you can also go one level more granular
you can also
do the thing that i just did on the
command line here in a graphical user
interface you can just
discard individual chunks but you can go
one level deeper you can say okay
these two lines here i want to discard
these two lines in the chunk
but the rest of the chunk should remain
intact
so you can really be very granular when
discarding changes
voila or even when you want to
stage things for the next commit when
you want to add changes
for the next commit that's staging and i
can say
this line here number 17 is part of the
next commit
but the other line is not so this
helps you produce very very granular
commits
and when you begin working or thinking
about that you might
say well this is over the top i think it
is not i think it really is very helpful
because there's a one big general
golden rule in version control and that
is
to commit semantically to commit only
topics in one commit that belong to the
same
overall topic right not to mix different
topics in the same commit
this is very important and when you want
to work in that way
working with changes in such a granular
way discarding chunks or even
lines and staging lines and chunks
becomes very very useful
and and helpful all right
git restore again but this time with the
dash
p flag
so enough sweet talk let's
put out the big guns and we want to do
undo
everything we did since we last
committed right this is for the the bad
days or for the bad
weeks maybe when you when you notice
you've programmed yourself into a dead
end
and you really want to start over you
want to get back to the last committed
state
and start over undo everything and let's
see how we can do that in git
all right this is case number four
and let's see what we have so again a
couple of changes in our
local working copy here and let's say we
really want to undo
all of them and get a clean working copy
this is again git restore but this time
with the
dot operator to say well everything in
this
location should be undone right if i do
that
and type git status once more voila
nothing to commit working tree clean
that's what we wanted to have um again
please be careful with this command you
are still working on
uncommitted local changes and if you
undo them
they're really gone so be a little bit
careful with those
okay good number
five so far from number one to number
four
we worked on those local changes
uncommitted local changes
and for the remainder of the workshop
we're going to work with
committed data right we are going to
manipulate
committed history so this is a totally
different
area of the workshop and a total
different area of
use cases and let's start with something
very simple again
fixing the very last commit because it's
very very common to mistype
your commit message or to simply forget
to add a certain change this is
something that can be done very easily
fixing the last
commit in git all right
number five and let's see what we have
okay so this is the very last commit
here
and you can see well a couple of typos
in the commit message
we should really fix that and let's do
that quickly
so on the command line you can use git
commit
dash dash amend that's the the crucial
part
and with dash m i can provide a new
commit message and hopefully this time a
better one
typos are indeed embarrassing
don't mistype embarrassing that's
embarrassing no looks good
okay and let's see what happened
and voila you might have seen it flicker
this very last commit has now been
corrected
with the commit message that we provided
with a new commit message so we fixed
that
the other type of problem let's say that
you can have with the
very last commit is that you forgot to
add a change
that should actually be part of that
commit and changing that is actually
pretty easy
you can simply add that to the staging
area that forgotten change
and then simply say amend again
it's the same thing on the command line
and then
click amend here and you'll see voila
index html is now part of that change
set two
right um little yellow warning box again
so amend is one of those commands that
rewrites
history as i said many of the the things
that we're
going to talk about we'll do that we'll
rewrite history
and this is a prime example and you
should keep
one rule in mind that will keep you
happy and
maintain your friendships amongst your
colleagues and guarantee a long
developer life
do not change commit history of things
that you have already
pushed that you have already shared on a
remote branch
this is very important because if you do
so then
the same history the re-written history
will be pushed again and that's gonna
cause trouble for your colleagues
who may have based their work on those
old commits so
never change history for commits that
have already been pushed
i'll show you what i mean by rewrite
history to make that a little bit
clearer i think that's that's helpful to
understand
so at the moment this very last commit
has a
commit hash of one two three five f d
nine a something like that if i do
another
amend i can do that as long as i want to
are indeed
very embarrassing amend
let's take another look and voila you
saw that the
the commit hash changed so git
is not able to somehow magically open
that commit in the background and then
exchange something and then
close it again what happens in the
background is that
a completely new commit object is
created
and swapped swaps out the the old one
right so the the old one is replaced
with a new one
and this is what rewriting history means
there
there are really new commits that are
exchanged in the background
okay number six
reverting a commit in the middle so
let's start with the good news here
c2 here is the bad guy but everything
that came
before that or after that is absolutely
fine we don't want to
throw away everything we just want to
undo c2
that commit here in the middle and
revert
has uh quite an a non-destructive way
let's say like that a non-destructive
way of of doing that
revert does not go ahead and rip out c2
and throw it away instead it creates a
new commit
c4 here in this little example here it
creates a new commit
that contains the opposite changes and
that's how it
undoes the problem you had in that
original commit so if you
look at that silly example here in the
old commit i changed
about this project into about and git is
clever enough to understand okay if i
uh introduce opposite changes i will
undo
the effects of that old commit pretty
clever
and very um very safe
let's say like that okay so
let's do this on the command line
and first of all let's have a look at
what we
could undo or revert in that case
let's say we want to revert this one
here right
so if i take a look at the change set
here
i can see that i changed about into
about this project so
i'm going to expect the opposite changes
when i do a revert on that commit right
okay so to revert this one i have to
remember the commit hash up here i'll
copy that to the clipboard and then
on the command line i can just type git
revert and the
hash of the commit that i want to undo
that's actually it
and i'm getting an editor window here
why is that
because as i said we are creating a new
commit that reverts the old
changes and creating a new commit means
there's a new commit message that i
could provide and this is the commit
message that i could
add i'll go with what git support
suggests here in this case that's
wonderful
because it's very very clear we revert
this commit here with this commit hash
that's that's wonderful i'll take that
save and close and take another look at
tower and see
voila we have a new commit that
undoes this one here by introducing
the opposite changes very practical
all right number
seven get revert and the commit hash
number seven is a little bit different
because here
everything that came after c2 is
actually bad so we really want to turn
back
time and go back to c2 and forget
everything that came afterwards
delete in air quotes delete everything
that came afterwards
and this is a case for the reset command
so let's see how we can do that
and again let's see what we want to do
and let's say we want to return to this
point in time here to this commit here
and forget everything that came
afterwards so we want to undo
delete remove however you want to put it
these commits that came later
again i need to remember the the commit
hash
to which i want to return this one here
and on the command line i can write git
reset
dash dash hard i'll explain the the
um the option in a second and then the
hash of the commit that we want to
return to
hola let's see okay you just saw it
flicker maybe
the newer commits disappeared and we're
now back
at this commit at a previous
state in time um you saw me use dash
dash
hard on the command line so if there's
desktop hard there might be other
options that's true
there's hard there's keep there's mix
there is
soft i think i i can never remember all
of the
the options you live a happy life with
hard
and mixed so you've seen hard hard means
no local changes should survive you
really want to have a clean working copy
mixed is a little bit different let's
let's see mixed
so the scenario here is the same i
prepared the same scenario twice
so we will go to this revision here
but this time using mixed and the
difference
is mixed keeps the
local changes or the changes contained
in the commits that we're going to undo
as local changes so these two commits
here will be undone
but they have a change set of course
they have changes
that are contained in in those commits
and
with using mixed we'll do that here
reset in tower we call it keep changes
on the command line it would be
mixed that's the same thing if we do
that
voila we return to that revision but
we also keep the changes that are
contained in those removed revisions
as local changes and you can hop into
your editor make some changes
discard things add things you're a
little bit more flexible with
mixed i would say
okay number seven git reset dash
hard and dash mixed
number eight so far we've mostly worked
on the complete
project or incomplete revisions and this
time i want to work on
just a single file sometimes you have
the situation that you know
a certain file was good at some point
but it's not
in in the current version and you want
to return time or turn back time
for just a single file not for the whole
project not for the whole
history just for a specific file
and you can do that with kit and let's
see how we can do that
and this is number
eight
and let's take a look at the scenario
okay so
in tower we have a quite a practical um
feature called the file history so
i can just right click any file and say
show me the files history this shows you
only the changes for that particular
file so you can very easily see how a
specific
file evolved over time and so we're
doing that for index html let's say
we only want to return to
this revision for index.html right this
is the
state of index html that we want to have
in our project
again so i'm going to copy the
hash here again
and on the command line you could guess
it's restore yeah git git restore
the source parameter the source is the
revision hash that i just copied and we
want to do that with index.html
voila and if i do that let's see what
happened
in the working copy i now have changes
that bring back
that version of index.html
this is these are the changes that bring
back that old version of the file again
all right git restore
source and you tell get from what source
revision you want to restore which file
all right for the next two cases i think
we're going to use a very specific
git tool called the ref log the reflog
you can think of uh
somehow like like git's diary i would
say a journal where
we get protocols every movement of the
head pointer
so what's a movement of the head pointer
you might ask so this is when you commit
when you check out when you reset when
you cherry pick when you
rebase actually all of the more
important actions are protocoled
in this journal and this of course makes
it perfect
for undoing mistakes and let's see what
we can do with the refloc
for example this here think back two
cases i think
number seven we did a reset right we
rolled back
to a specific older revision
and did that with the reset command and
then sometimes
numbers three and four follow you
sometimes notice oh damn
i shouldn't have done that that was the
wrong move and then the panic emoji con
often follows
and let's see if we can use reflog to
undo that and to get back those
seemingly lost
commits right that's the thing we want
to do
okay number nine
okay so let's say again we want to
return to this revision here and
by doing that these newer commits here
will disappear will get
deleted in air quotes so again a reset
we don't need to keep changes and boom
everything newer is now gone
and i'll give you a second or two to
notice oh damn
we shouldn't have done that and we we
dearly miss our commits already and
let's see if we can use the reflux to
get them back
so get refloc to open up the the journal
that i just talked about
and it's it's ordered chronologically so
the most recent
actions are at the top and if you look
at the topmost item you see
okay there's a reset and we just did
that 20 seconds ago or 10 seconds ago
so the journal works and if we want to
undo that
the good news is we can just use the
state before
and restore that one so i'll just copy
this here to the
clipboard and then i could totally use
git reset once more that's possible
but i prefer to create a new branch
let's call that happy ending and let's
start that branch
at that revision before we
did that mistake and let's see
what happened okay happy ending voila
here are the commits that we
thought we had just lost wonderful we
saved the day i think
um the refloc if any tower users are
amongst you
the reflux is also part of the newer
versions of tower if you don't see it in
your version
probably you don't you haven't activated
it yet
you can activate that in the preferences
here show reflog in the sidebar because
it's
some kind of a an advanced feature not
everybody needs it
but if you want to have it you can
activate it and you can
have the different branches sorted
and a great tool so you can see what
happened in your git repository
all right that was recovering deleted
commits with the ref log
and you can also do other things with
the ref log for example this here
recovering a deleted branch for example
so let's say you have worked on a
feature branch for some time and
your team lead or your boss or
customer says you don't need that
feature anymore so
to tidy up you delete that and
again numbers three and four sometimes
follow
the feature is not out of the picture
just yet and it returns and
you notice it was a bad idea deleting
that and the panic emoji
follows let's see how we can undo that
with git
and this is case number 10
all right so at the moment we have a
beautiful
feature login branch that also contains
a commit that is present
nowhere else so we are going to delete
this branch in a second
and we're really going to delete data
right
this commit is present nowhere else so
we're losing data right now
we'll go on the first thing i have to do
is step away from this branch because
currently this is the head branch and i
can't delete the current branch so i'll
double click master to check it out and
then
right click feature login and say delete
i have to force deletion because it
contains data that is present nowhere
else
and voila okay so
boom panic we noticed that this
actually wasn't a good idea and we need
that branch back
and let's see how we can do that with
the refloc
again git reflog and you notice
the most recent item here is the
checkout that we just did
before deleting that branch and that's
of course
our lucky day because we can just return
to the state before
again and restore this one to
undo what we just did and
in this case of course get branch for
creating a new branch makes a lot of
sense and i think it was called
feature login if i'm right and again it
should
start at the state before the state
we just thought we had lost
okay feature login seems to be back
and including that seemingly lost commit
so we just
undid that and saved that valuable part
of our work
one thing i want to show you in tower um
since i don't know a couple of versions
ago we introduced a very very helpful
feature
um connected to undoing things
when you want to undo something in your
text editor you can just
hit command z right it's as easy as that
and we implemented that for git
so if i just delete that once more
delete
feature login force delete
and then hit command z voila the branch
is back
and this works for deleting branches for
deleting commits
for staging unstaging discarding changes
from making resets for almost
anything so you don't have to actually
know
the different commands that you need to
undo things you just need to
type command z and that's it very very
powerful
very practical all right
git reflux again and let's move on to
number 11
moving a commit to a new branch so the
problem here is that we have committed
to the wrong branch and many teams have
a convention that says
you shouldn't commit to a long-running
branch like
master or develop those
branches should only receive commits by
integration right by merging or rebasing
not directly committing to them but
still we do because well
we mess up we're on that branch and we
type git commit and then it has happened
actually in this case we should have
created a separate feature branch a new
feature branch
and committed there and let's see if we
can clean up the scenario
so that it looks like that like it
should look
okay
and let's see what we have
okay so the very last commit on master
is start new login feature and of course
that smells
that should have been the new feature
branch that i just talked about
and the good news is master already has
the state that our new feature brand
should have
so we can just use that as a basis
to create a new branch feature
login and voila
so now we have that feature branch
feature login
that contains that commit everything is
okay on
on that branch but the second part of
that solution is of course
to clean up master because master is
currently in a dirty state
it shouldn't contain that commit this
last one here
so let's move back to master check it
out double click
and then simply make a reset
don't need to keep changes and voila
master is now clean that commit that
shouldn't have been there
here is not here anymore and feature
login has
the correct state so nobody will ever
find out
you keep a wonderful reputation amongst
your colleagues
on the command line you create that
feature branch get branch feature login
and then you clean up master by using
git reset
head tilde one means one behind the head
so you don't have to copy the the commit
hashes all the time
and we're doing that with the heart
option
all right number 12 looks similar but
it's a little bit different
the problem is the same we committed on
the wrong
branch but this time the feature branch
is already present right we don't have
to
create that feature branch it's already
there we just
just in our quotes have to move over
that commit
to its correct branch and then clean up
let's see how we can do that
all right this is number 12.
and let's take a look at the scenario
okay so
on master the latest commit reads
newsletter sign up page okay
while we are having a feature newsletter
branch
so my suggestion is this commit
should have been here and not on master
right
so to do that let's move over to feature
newsletter
and then cherry pick that's a new tool
we haven't used yet
use cherry pick to move over that commit
right cherry pick
and voila feature newsletter now
contains that commit
like it should have been in the first
place and master
still has that so again like in the case
before we have to clean
up we just reset to that state before
well we have to
check that out we reset to the state
before
voila master is clean the the
commit that should have never been there
is not there anymore
and feature newsletter contains the
commit that we moved over
using cherry pick on the command line a
little bit more to do
get checkout to move to that feature
branch then get cherry pick
to move that commit over go back to
master
and then again cleanup master using git
reset
hard all right for the last
i think five cases we're going to use
interactive rebase
by some called the swiss army knife of
git tools which i
find quite fitting because a swiss army
knife has lots of different tools
but it's still a knife so you could
theoretically cut yourself a little bit
if you keep that golden rule in mind
to not change commit history that has
already been pushed
then you're fine so many of the the the
tools
that we have talked about and that we
will talk about
are there for a very specific use case
that will help you
clean up your local commit history
before you
merge that back into a team branch right
so you've worked on a feature branch for
some time
and you could do some cleanup let's say
and you can use all of the tools that i
just showed you and that i'm going to
show you
to do that cleanup and then move it back
integrate it merge it into a master or
develop or a shared branch and push it
so interactive rebase what can you do
with that you can
edit old commit messages delete commits
uh
combine multiple commits to into one
split
commits a lot of different things and
let's start with
very simple case let's edit an old
commit message to to show you how
interactive rebase works so you might
say well we've done that
tobias in case number five if i'm right
we've edited an old commit message
then back then it was the very last
commit and that's pretty easy you can
use git commit
amend for that case but if we're talking
about something further back in the
commit history
amend is not available anymore you have
to use interactive rebase to do that
and since this this is quite an easy
case it's perfect to illustrate how
interactive rebase works in general so
very generally speaking you have three
big steps with every interactive rebase
session the first is you have to ask
yourself
how far back in time in history
do i want to go what should be the new
base commit what part of
commit history do i want to manipulate
and then you actually start the
interactive rebase session that's step
number two
and then you will see an editor window
where you can
determine which actions you want to
perform and i'll
have some comments on that uh when we
see that in practice and let's
i'd say we check that out in practice
and then discuss
things a little bit more okay
number 13
and let's see what commit we could
change so let's say we want to change
the commit
message of this old commit here again
remember if it had been this one no
problem
git commit amend wonderful but anything
older than that
we need interactive rebase for so first
step in interactive rebase
how far back in history in time do i
want to go
i could either copy the the commit hash
or do a little bit of counting
the answer is at least to the parent
commit of the one that i want to change
right
at least to the parent commit so either
i copy this commit hash or
say head minus one minus two minus 3
and let's start git rebase
interactive head tilde 3 we said n minus
3
and let's start
voila this is the editor window that i
mentioned
two notes about this editor window
first the order of commits seems
reversed right so if you take a look at
the
the bottom most improved headline for
imprint
that's actually the top most here in the
real history don't be confused by that
that's okay
from git's perspective we're doing an
interactive rebase and
git has to reapply the old commits
step by step so the reversed order is
okay
the second note here is we do not go
ahead
and make our changes we do not change
the commit history
the commit message right here but we
only
mark up what we want to do with that
commit and
in in this case we want to reword reword
is documented here
use the commit but edit the commit
message we want to edit the commit
message
so save and close after marking that
line
with reword save close
and now finally i can really
edit the commit message now is the time
to make my changes
optimize the general markup structure in
index
page close save and close
and if we take a look at tower we will
see
wow here it is now it says optimize
the general markup structure in index
page
so we just manipulated history although
just git history but
a very special case here
all right get rebased
to edit an old commit message you can
also use git rebase
to delete an old commit so
sometimes not often probably but
sometimes you really have a commit that
shouldn't have been there
at all and interactive rebase allows you
to really delete that
from the history let's see how we can do
that in
practice that's number
14.
and let's see what we can delete um
well let's say we want to delete this
one right
so again it's still an interactive
rebase session so
first step how far back in history do i
do i need to go
at least the parent commit so either
copy this one here
or head minus one minus two
git rebase dash interactive head
tilt d2 and
voila the editor is back and we said we
wanted to delete
this one here and i can mark this with
drop drop is the action keyword for
deleting a commit
you could also that's the exception from
the rule you could really just
delete that line it's an editor right
you can manipulate the text here you can
delete that line and save and close
that will also remove the commit that's
also okay
but i think it's it's better to stick to
the official way of doing things and to
properly mark up the line with what you
want to do to it
so drop save and close
and if we take a look at the history
voila you just saw it flicker
the commit was removed was deleted from
the history that's possible
with interactive rebase
number 15 you can also squash multiple
odes commit into
old commits into one so
in general the the rule in in version
control is to commit
granularly and rather smaller than
bigger
but sometimes you might have overdone
that let's say and you want to combine
multiple commits
into one and that's also possible with
interactive rebase
and git all right
number 15
and let's see what we can combine and i
would say let's combine
these fellas here right these two should
be one
melted into one and again it's
interactive rebase so
we have to do the little counting game
so at least the parent commit
so this is ahead minus one two three
and let's start that git
rebase dash interactive head
till d3
and voila so we said we want to combine
these two commits right and the the tool
we're going to use here is
squash squash is there to meld
combine multiple commits into one and
the one thing you have to know about
squash to use it is
the line i am marking up
will be combined with the line before
the line above so by marking up line
number two i will combine it with
line number one and that's what we want
so let's
save and close and
again i do get an editor window why is
that
that by melting those two commits into
one
a new commit is going to be created and
a new commit means
i can provide a new commit message so
combine
two into one i'll leave the the old
commit messages here just
just in there for us as an overview
i could of cour of course change that
too
and voila
here we go we have combined the change
sets of course
and provided a new commit message here
so we combine
two old commits into one new one
pretty awesome again a note about how to
do that in tower it's
pretty easy to do things like these in
tower you can just
drag and drop and this will be a squash
right you will combine that
very easy so
number 16 second to last and actually my
my favorite case
because it's very very very practical so
the scenario is number one we made a
mistake
it doesn't matter what it is we could
have forgotten to add something we
should have deleted something
we mistyped something it doesn't matter
a mistake right
and the the normal reaction number two
is to add our corrections in a new
commit
right that's that's just normal that's
that's okay
the problem with this approach is we
have that original commit
c2 and we have a correcting commit a
band-aid commit
c4 right and if you do that a couple of
times
original band-aid original band-aid
your commit history becomes unreadable
because nobody understands okay
why is that commit here shouldn't have
that been here
and you have lots of commits and and
no semantics actually that band-aid
commit
doesn't have any semantic meaning it's
just there to fix an earlier mistake
right
and the beauty of the tool we're going
to use here
which is called fix up the beauty is
that we're going to use that band-aid
commit
apply it to the original one
and the band-aid gets thrown away right
that mt
commit that non-semantical commit that
newer one that fix up commit
is disposed and the original commit
appears to be perfect from the start
very beautiful all right enough talk
let's do this
um
and let's see what we have okay
so let's say that
this commit here is not complete right
we made a mistake here
and let's also see say that what i
prepared here
changes in error html would fix that
mistake right at the moment
error html is not part of the change set
here
but adding it to the change set would
make it complete
so first step is to simply
add that change to the staging area
and to commit it but not a normal commit
we are going to use fix up as a
as an option and we go we want to fix up
this old commit here right that new
commit that we are producing
should fix this old one and we're going
to
copy that to the clipboard the commit
hash of that one
fix up whoa with an x
right so if you read that it says this
new commit here
fixes this old commit here okay
let's do that and you probably expected
fireworks or something
spectacular but i'm very sorry we just
produced
a new commit with that command but
something is cooking here right fix up
exclamation mark is prefixed
so something is happening here okay
the second part of that solution is to
use interactive rebase of course we're
still in that department of the workshop
so we're going to use interactive rebase
to fix this one
first step in interactive rebase how far
back do i need to go at least the parent
so hit minus one two three
four that's the one we want to correct
so at least
here all right git
rebase interactive head tilt d4
and the second part of that secret sauce
here
is to use dash dash auto squash
right first part is fix up when you
commit
second part is auto squash when you
start the interactive rebase that's a
two-part solution
and the good news is in this editor
window i don't have to do
anything git already did all of the hard
work for us and i'll explain that to you
but
just keep in mind nothing to do for us
i'll explain
what happened and why so the first thing
that git does
did for us is to mark up that band aid
commit here
as fix up right this is the fix up
commit
that's the first thing i didn't do that
it's automatically here
and the second thing that git did is it
automatically
sorted this line to the right position
right
because actually change headlines for
about an imprint the fix up commit
should be the bottom most right reverse
order
so it should be down here but git
already understood okay
we want to use this to fix up that other
old commit so i'll position it here
because it works just like squash squash
you remember
the rule squash combines with the line
above fix up also combines with the line
above so nothing to do for us
just save and close and if you take a
look at
that this is the one we fixed up
and now it contains error html it is
correct
and the ugly band-aid commit has been
thrown away
wonderful beautiful commit history
nothing is dirty nothing seems to
have been broken everything's fine
again if you want to do that in tower
very very simple
just drag and drop and keep the option
key
pressed and voila this is a fix
up very very easy
okay um git commit fix up
and get rebus interactive auto squash a
two-part solution
and here we are at the last case of this
workshop
and this is actually just to to show off
a little bit
about what interactive rebase can do
because the answer is
anything actually anything so split
or edit really opens up an old commit
for editing it again very very beautiful
so um we can edit that old commit
add new changes delete something add
files and then make multiple new commits
out of that
change set very very flexible and let's
see how we can do that
this one is quite a lot of work to do on
the
command line so i'll show you how to do
this in tower and you know that it's
possible
if you ever want to do that we need
something that has a couple of changes
so let's take this one so in tower i can
just right click
and say edit and this
brings me right into the middle of an
interactive rebase session
where the whole contents of that old
commits are here
in my local working copy so i could just
as i said
hop into an editor make some changes or
say well
this here really doesn't make sense i'll
throw that away
and this and
this is actually one topic so commit
number one we wanna uh as i said the the
general rule is to commit only things
that belong to the same topic so this is
one topic
and this is actually a second topic so
let's make
that commit to
and then i can hit continue continue
closes the interactive rebase session
and voila i just split
edited an old commit and created two
new ones out of that very very flexible
and allows you to clean up your history
in a very elegant way
all right i think i've said it a
bazillion times but let's say it one
more time
many of the tools today that i showed
you
do rewrite history and the rule to live
by
is don't use these tools for read
writing commit history that has already
been pushed
to a shared repository right use those
things
to clean up your local history before
you merge that back into
a team branch and this is true for
amending commits rebase
interactive rebates definitely sometimes
reset so
be a little bit careful and use those
only in the right
situations all right
what we have done is we've created
little videos of those 17 cases and a
very handy cheat sheet
with some problem situations and the
solution for that
if you want to get that that's free to
go so go at bitly
and get first aid kit if you want to
download that
that's it from me thank you very much
for your attention
and i would say have fun breaking things
and of course repairing goodbye
you